الان صور همم طبعا للملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز العاهل السعودي وهو يستقبل الرئيس
همم الصيني
جنبينج في العاصمه السعوديه الرياضيه
يستقبله بحضور ولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان الملك سلمان وقع مع الرئيس الصيني
اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
البلدين اذن الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
يوقع في هذه الاثناء في هذه الصور التي
نتبعها على شاشه العربيه يوقع مع الرئيس
الصيني اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله بين البلدين همم الملك سلمان كما
ذكرنا وقع مع الرئيس الصيني
اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
بلدين همم تاتي طبعا همم من ضمن الاتفاقيه
التي همم
وقعت كذلك تبع بالامس اكتر من 35 اتفاقيه
وقعت همم بين الجانبين السعودي والصيني
اليوم وهذه الاتفاقيه المهمه التي يوقعها
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز مع الرئيس
الصيني اتفاقيه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
شامله بين البلدين كان همم الامير محمد بن
سلمان ولي العهد السعودي قد عقد جلسه
مباحثات رسميه مع الرئيس الصيني همم هذا
اليوم كذلك بحضور ولي العهد السعودي تم
منح الرئيس الصيني همم
الدكتوره الفخريه من جامعه الملك سعود